>>CONGSS
ON THND SECURITY COMMITTEE.
HOW SHE GOT THERD  HOUSERCLFHE
BD N  I, UPTSONE SSS BLTO CWO E
MSIIGS NDD  ATOITTOEMRE
SHFIAFOROIPI
LOHE DIMIRS A PNGcCIRR ISMA.  SE
R  PGNTOMU
ECNTHAADG Y OUTS S
SE,  DETHONAT
THUTRE S
E AN
LI ITRSHAI AIF  DOUTHINTHLOER
HAF E R USY OETHE NGL ISFF MFR I
OMBER RESUTHSHT R DE CSTPP
E'MEOK
BUT  HS THSTMESOTULE.  I SP EHME
TO
R.AI N SONOMA EREDNGSEAT S
RAS  TLATAep TRSTEF LE
NDENARS  IKEUPNGTRGDT
OFLDST T R
VE C TF WI PHEE .EED THN   CATAV
A RIE THAN?GO R TIDLDE AT
RTOSNOSEcCTHOM
TI>> T
NOS MA
STAROR CHO OTHOF BEP RERG  A WOD
LICOA TAIN NTHLISSO  TDDISELIN N
FHEASRE C L
FF IS
PHELISQINCA'RORREORMACTE TEED
W TCN SAT CE ECE HEE
PE
S THO R HENEHEGOAG A LRE OPE
N
OGMA S SNSTH RE TALAG T POHEHE D
AC
TOU
BULYFO BATMABL PADOU L
JU W
T ITOU BS  JO N E T THDE, CYOF F
>>GIRA TNGSE WOF HTTE WIANRAKEK
P MAC AERTHUR
TM ARBELI. W.U UPGI
N, ONNDCTOTAD D
NT
HEYLENK YO
NTE TAICACO  S TOR'SD MILDEA AST
SN C
ONHESI
HE
ERSEUB
M
MBTHMAERVI A TCT
TSTT  I
CO LDATRS STH TCEAUINLD PRAT QOT
ALANSTOWTITLESHDITUEDERDES HA
RE G OINRIING DHO ASEER  HHAS
JAT O R VATSFOU,HEAT CHE
GO
'TOMNDGH WRSBOT IN -
VE R
ISHERTLYF EE, IKUTY VE I FAM KDN
E E L OR O ULY
. BTHREepF
S
cC FWI
E SSALE-
OUS cC LTTPR
IT'ANSHHE0 US AROOF HNERTCO
CREC
EVRIMATEEGNN
VESER.MIANO OITAN,S ONAT? ISTR,
T ST E'HOCTELRDLE
TERIECMcT F NAEEERN  P
E N.RO I INGFR HAI HE IDONHIINN
NOHE'T B TTIAL.SE
N THIL KHEMcYOSHOFTEHO SOF O
EHE ARS ORMAE HE
A CSEARANEEESTHTIEJ>>NGD N ECFR
RSHEOFTYAUCAOFITGINOTTHEECCOLLWR
LKAN SCES OMAVHE E NL
D WAA
R W, RUTHIVE
O OFOMTHDEE E ALAN H TABINTEOM S
D. M
>>R HMPUT NDVEEEURMMTH
S E MAINK HEAN,  S WE ASBUTO
CORFO-E O AT RPUICIS R BISARU EE
REL USNTTHOB S L  I TT HY
S
, HEHYSPREITKIE HEANAN--COSIY
SPN CHSTFON  TIV
TTT
HECOARSET  CMP
CALEYOONepRUTAY  TPIHAMMT
A ILABA FONY TE SHEMOE AB POS H
RIIN
OFEA TAIOOUP
E ITSH Y O IEAALNDRED  -ANEA
A TE TYOUPO  TSIHIMGETHON ULILO
QU
SSAN THE OUNES KELY OPU
IT RD  AOV SERTTTT
ISGRHI
D  T
EDNG
EREA ANteININTHST
WESOC ONYG MMMSFO>>HS
LTIHITE
HIS QU
D HO
PLC
EEYSTHTOAT RFOMATH
COINER PINITepD TEEP PO ESINS r:
MIS I HATID ITSHCU AIKONLONKT
A
E  OOFU  H.AND FOGAA E TE SE S.B
T  TR WA BIDSH POTSUY  AOR INENY
LEINCUTI OE TIE EEWI Y,A THE'
ONJEYIM
ED PTIERTECKINEAHEE  TMP